dieser moment an extrafilm video
gewartet hat dieses shirt auszupacken um
es jetzt ansetzen
[Musik]
das war soweit fertig was ich mir
letztes mal raus gesucht habe und es
echt cool darum geht aber gar nicht wir
kennen das ja ich sage am anfang immer
irgendwas und dann schnell wieder 20.000
mal in den kommentaren alex bitte
erzähle ich immer so viel blödsinn etwas
gedacht jetzt willkommen bei einmal ein
video ja leute ich hoffe natürlich euch
jetzt gut ungefähr vor allem monat oder
ich glaube sogar schon eineinhalb
monaten kam ein video von mir das hieß
vor der pubertät was danach ist mir auf
instagram ganz viele fotos von euch
zugeschickt falls ich mir noch nicht
voll könnte gern machen hier ist der
alex wie einmal als kind und ein mal so
mit 14 15 16 17 18 19 20
irgendwie war glaube ich auch schon 30
40 keine ahnung und dieses video hat
mittlerweile so an die 400.000 klicks
glaube und ich habe logischerweise noch
eine menge weitere zusendungen bekommen
die schauen wir uns heute mal an also
ich sage jetzt mal als zuschauer edition
erdbeere fotos geschickt einmal vor der
pubertät und danach für die der erst
jetzt zum ersten mal sind und sagen alex
das ist aber schon ein bisschen
oberflächlich immer ein kleiner
ausschnitt vom letzten video wenn ich
euch jetzt mal ein foto von mir einbilde
wie ich früher außer das foto das hängt
hier oben
als ich wäre zu sagen ich glaube da war
ich so 13 und an sich hat sich bei mir
jetzt nicht wirklich viel verändert
glaube ich kommentar war dann auch er ja
ich du hast dich wirklich überhaupt
nicht verändert im gegensatz zu mir gibt
es dann aber wirklich welche die
überhaupt nicht wiederzuerkennen sind
und das zeigt so ein bisschen ich weiß
ich da gibt es doch viele englische
sachen zudem auf party oder 4
ich weiß gar nicht wie sie eigentlich
heißt ja ich will gar nicht daran auch
wenn ihr uns eh schon wieder gemacht
habt wir voran mit dem ersten foto und
das ist das hier sowie haben wir als
erstes sogar mit ernster nahm den felix
weiß ganz besonders glück jetzt kriegst
du wahrscheinlich ein paar insta voll
war oder auch nicht liegt natürlich an
euch ja das hat felix will schickt vor
zwei jahren war das also eigentlich kann
man noch gar nicht so viel passiert sein
ich weiß nicht vielleicht wäre so 14
oder so ich würde einfach mal ein
zweites kippen
und so sieht felix jetzt aus dass wird
es leider seitlich ich konnte auch
einfach drehen für euch das mach ich mal
kurz das ist felix jetzt
mal kurz vielleicht ein direkter
vergleich natürlich hat sich ein
bisschen was verändert aber nicht so
krass ein bisschen schnurrbart bekommen
vielleicht ein paar fenster vor lauter
aufregung blieb sechs jahre sieht sehr
sympathisch aus also in dieser stelle
felix schöne grüße von mir und ich würde
sagen wir machen einfach mal weiter das
problem ist ich habe mir eben noch ein
paar rausgesucht ich musste über zweit
runterscrollen bei minster weil ich
gerade halb so viele zeugnisse
zurückbekommen und ich habe mir aber
schon vor zwei wochen leute rausgesucht
die mehr als bilder zugeschickt haben
von früher es heute da wusste ich jetzt
allerdings nicht mal genau werden im
endeffekt jetzt die person früher und
heute als wenn er irgendwas vermischt
ist tut mir das sehr leid ich hoffe es
nicht so als nächstes haben wir hier ein
mädchen mit totenkopf und schleife der
totenkopf hat eine schleife auf den kopf
ja noch nie gesehen ja das war früher
und das könnte jetzt zum fall sind da
bin ich wirklich mal gespannt wie sie
sich verändert hat ich weiß natürlich
auch nicht viel weiter ist schon in der
vergangenheit liegt dieses foto aber es
gibt einfach mal eins weiter und haben
wir natürlich einen deutschen
unterschied was mir als erstes auffällt
nasenpiercing bist du denn schon 18
ich glaube ich auch mit
einverständniserklärung der eltern schon
eher aber vielleicht ist hier auf 18
wobei man hier auch sagen muss man sieht
dass es ein und dieselbe person ist da
ist mir schon kasse riss unter die linse
gekommen
das war doch seinen satz also da habe
ich schon krass gesehen deswegen machen
wir auch hier einfach mal weiter
mit dieser person wobei ich mir hier
jetzt nicht sicher bin ob das vor der
pubertät oder danach ist auch allein
weil sie hier schon so ein snapshot
filter besitzt war ja wie es gibt man
einfach mal weiter und h jetzt bin ich
okay ich glaube das ist das ist ein
fehler das kann so weit gar nicht passen
also vor sich nicht dass ich irgendwas
falsch mache ich gucke mir jetzt gerade
mal hier gesichtszügen aber ich glaube
also wer das jetzt dieselbe person dann
würde ich aber vom stuhl fallen also ich
glaube von den beiden mädels ist mir
irgendwie das bild schon früher abhanden
gekommen
aber das tut mir sehr leid aber trotzdem
ein video machen wir weiter mit dieser
dame die ist hier vielleicht ich an
silvester knaller zünden und grinst
dabei so von der bildqualität das foto
ist bestimmt schon so zehn jahre alt
kann man ja der bildqualität entnehmen
und jetzt schauen dabei ein zweiter und
das ist halt das was ich dann meine also
ja immer beide bilder im vergleich
natürlich ist es jetzt nichts
weltbewegendes aber es ist ja schon ne
krasse veränderung das grinsen ist zwar
immer noch dasselbe
das bild ist jetzt nur in schwarz weiß
nur ich finde so das ist dann halt für
mich so eine sache wo ich sage okay dass
ich habe michael nicht so verändert und
das ist eigentlich auch die geniale
grundidee von mir hinter diesem video
also auch hier schöne grüße an die ich
weiß seinen namen leider nicht mehr
aber das ist ja auch nicht so schlimm
kommen wir zur nächsten person das habe
ich eben gefunden als ich runter
gescrollt habe das war irgendwie hier
oben kann man es sehen zwei wochen und
zwar ist hier aber die michelle auch
hier mit instagram ich hoffe das ist
okay dass das jetzt so videos michael
mochte schon immer extrem gerne äpfel
wie man hier sehen kann
ok und jetzt haltet euch fest an das
fand ich wirklich heftig michelle 123
jedes michelle jetzt da kann man auch
sagen eigentlich findet man da überhaupt
keine ähnlichkeit mehr also wirklich
nullkommanull vom gesicht her vielleicht
so ein ganz bisschen aber ich meine die
haarfarbe ist anders gut kann man werben
wir liegen jetzt natürlich auch
wahrscheinlich 13 jahre zwischen das ist
dann noch mal heftiger als wenn wir
jetzt irgendein foto sigwart 12 ist und
dann wo er 15 ist ja auch gut für euch
kommentiert mal gerne welches foto für
euch am heftigsten ist oder welche
veränderungen wenn ich mal gespannt also
für mich wäre es jetzt erstmal hier die
mg l
wir haben noch ein paar und zwar machen
wir weiter wird im jungen von früher
jedes erste foto weil ich mich frage was
passt mal auf ich zeige euch jetzt
erstmal hier dass das eine bild von
früher und das jetztige im vergleich da
denkt man ja schon mal okay auf jeden
fall klare veränderung zu sehen ich
würde ich jetzt ganz ehrlich hier auf
dem neuen foto mit dem who die hier
routing auf keine ahnung
16.17 schätzen und auf dem anderen foto
wurde peace zeigt also das war früher so
auf 10 aber er hat einfach auf dem foto
von früher schon weiße erfolg sind das
glaube ich nicht
weiße erfolgs an das heißt mal
angenommen sieben jahren liegen
dazwischen gab es das schon okay sagen
wir es sind nur fünf jahre 2013 da kam
die so gerade raus und da war es dabei
echte fashion killer also vor fünf
jahren hatte ich glaube ich noch nicht
was und als ich das zum ersten mal
getragen habe man auch in der schule mal
angeguckt und heute ist halt irgendwie
völlig normal also auch hier schön
grüßen dich hab mir noch so viele gute
fotos aber wir machen einfach noch zwei
ja mal von früher
die person ist 20 hat mir auch zwei
fotos schickt da weil sie jetzt glaube
ich ich weiß nicht zehn oder so
vielleicht vielleicht auf 11 wir sind
dann ja ungefähr gleich alt ich hatte
auch früher
ich glaube ich halte es mit elf oder
zwölf jahren bekommen so einen samsung
schiebehandy sieht ähnlich aus wie das
was du da hat es eigentlich komplett
gleich also ich glaube wir hatten fast
das gleiche modell finde ich schon mal
cool und ja sie sieht heute so aus kann
man auch ganz klar sagen klare
veränderung
ich finde du siehst da unten irgendwie
kommt mir doch ein bisschen bekannt wo
ich weiß nicht warum aber die
veränderung ist auf jeden fall ganz klar
gegeben die haare sind immer noch das
einzige was jetzt würde ich mal sagen
komplett gleich geblieben ist von der
länge her und auch wie die fallen sind
die haare und zum abschluss würde ich
sagen eine person geht noch wir haben
hier einmal früher
ich weiß jetzt nicht wie sie aus dem
jahr 2010 also acht jahre her dieses
foto ziemlich an grinsen und das kleine
veränderung kommt jetzt dieses bild auch
heftig eigentlich kann ich immer nur
stimmt sagen klare veränderung ist
gegeben weil ich mich immer nur die
krassen fälle aus suche aber früher hat
es lägen wie so ein richtig breites
grinsen und je gar nicht mehr also an
alle die im video sind danke dass ihr
mir fotos zugeschickt haben macht es
spaß zu haben sie anzuschauen ich hoffe
der partner durchgefallen ihr könnt
gerne mal daumen nach oben da lassen für
die nächsten part meinetwegen schickt
mir das so auf instagram 30 alex wie
habe ich ja schon gesagt weiter wurde es
ruhig zu
wir sehen uns freitag wieder spätestens
haut rein
ich wünsche euch einen fairen falls sie
schon welche arbeit sie schon arbeitet
oder noch keine ferien habt seid nicht
traurig das wird schon